the enemy does not sleep  he waits  a dark and cunning sorcerer  he has not one name but  many we knew him  a sauron  [Music]  we thought the war  at last  was ended  today  our days of peace  begin  we thought our joys would be unending  we thought our light  would never dim  the skies  are strange  [Music]  it is  [Music]  evil does not sleep  it wins  beyond the darkness tempting shadow  to barriers all beneath the mountain  [Music]  he has no one name but many  sour  if the evil rising is left unchecked  it will take us off  find the light  and the shadow will not find you  together we can survive this  fight with me  each of us  must decide who we shall be  there can be no trust between hammer and  rock  eventually one or the other  must surely break  you have been told many lies of middle  earth  you